(upbeat electric guitar music)
- [Announcer] Who's the
fairest of them all?
We're going to find out by pitching
two of the world's most bad-ass
women against each other
in a head-to-head battle.
First up, Snow White.
Don't let the name fool you,
or the fact she's been
asleep for a long time.
She has a solid command of martial arts,
including German jiu-jitsu and fencing,
as well as the ability to
bend the will of nature
to her command.
She has at her faculty, a
number of special attacks,
including a leaping nature fist and rage,
which increases her overall power
the more she gets attacked.
She is also rumored to be nearly immortal
and will tend to sleep
off any mortal wounds.
On the other side of the field we have
the spirit of the north, Elsa,
who simply cannot let it go.
A grudge, that is.
Her ability to magically
control ice is only bested
by her temper and her strong
command of muay Thai boxing.
Her fighting regime is bolstered by
two blistering special
attacks, freeze touch and
avalanche, a vice grip-like attack
which is rumored to be inescapable.
Elsa is widely considered one of the
most powerful women alive.
- I'm going to go with
Snow White, cuz she's O.G.
- Elsa has the advantage.
Although, Snow White's pretty scrappy,
cuz she grew up in the woods.
- Snow White has nothing
on Elsa, except for all
of her woodland creatures
would like ban to her side.
And so I think that would
give her a fighting chance.
But I legit think Elsa
would kick Snow White's ass.
Like pretty intensely.
- Snow White has to be
rescued by a prince,
she doesn't wield any sort of weaponry.
Sounds like Elsa at least has powers.
- Snow White always kinda
felt like she had her
head in the clouds, you know what I mean?
Whereas Elsa straight-up
almost killed her sister.
- [Announcer] Well, there you have it.
Our fighters are geared
up and ready to go.
Let's see who'll win this royal battle.
(upbeat music)
Elsa starts out with flurry of attacks,
easily blocked by Snow White, who parries,
as if floating on a cloud.
Clinch.
Elsa has the advantage here, if she can.
There we go, it's the freeze touch.
She's very shaken up by that left hook,
but as the fight progresses,
Snow White becomes
enraged and more powerful.
She's back at it, going for the take down.
Eats a couple of ice-hot
elbows to the back.
Snow White now with a nice shoulder throw.
(blows landing)
Elsa is down and Snow
White is on the offensive.
(grunting)
Elsa is fighting back.
She's raging hard.
Now Snow White has launched
into her leaping nature fist.
Can Elsa get out the way?
(blow landing)
Oh, big blow.
Snow White has the advantage
here, now on the ground,
going for the rear naked choke.
(grunting)
Oh, but she can't sink it.
She better watch out.
Elsa is dangerous on the ground.
Oh, no, she's got her.
Avalanche.
This doesn't look good.
This could be the end, folks.
- Go. Let it go.
- [Announcer] And Snow White is asleep.
(upbeat electric guitar music)